well thanks that's that's a very kind
welcome from a friend and a colleague
and i'm really happy to be here at this
inaugural we can call it that stoic on x
norway hopefully we'll be doing this for
years to come
and it's great to see the the interest
and growth in stoicism so when
when harold proposed this to me
originally i thought well let's talk
about things that people run into that
are real challenges and problems that
come up you know like in the stoic
meeting groups
and whether they be face to face or
online or in facebook you know you
notice the largest one that has like
tens of thousands of people belonging to
it and you also notice that a lot of the
same
problems and challenges keep coming up
over and over again
and there's there's good reasons for
that
and then you know i came on to say
this sort of title idea of stoic
stumbling blocks and and what i mean by
them are
scandalone uh things that you know you
literally trip over or that stand in the
way we'll talk about that in just a bit
and then after i'd given this a lot of
thought and we'd talked about it harold
said well you know the people here are
probably not going to be beginners but
much more
advanced
students of stoicism people who have a
solid background in practice and
knowledge
and i thought well okay
i can still do the same presentation
more or less because
it's not like
stoicism just like any other virtue
ethics or intentional way of living it's
not like a role playing game or like a
video game where you level up and once
you make it from level one to level two
you've left level one behind all
together i think we still run into a lot
of the same
issues over and over again sometimes we
have more tools
and we've got better perspective on it
but it's not as if i think any of us
unless we're really fortunate are going
to be completely free of these
stumbling blocks in our life and i want
to say a little bit about stumbling
blocks
to begin with so i mentioned you know
scondalone the word we get scandal from
in greek
this is something that you
run into and you trip over
or
you know it discourages you and dismays
you it steers you aside from where
you're going so i think that's one kind
of stumbling block and then another term
that gets used a lot
especially in epictetus is
emporista the things that
it's written as hindrances or
the things you could actually like put
on your legs to hobble you
there there are things that stand in our
way
and keep us from being able to pursue
the path that we want to be on they
restrict us they interfere with us
and we run into these pretty frequently
there's ways of dealing with them
and ways of not being
you could say
disabled by them
and and so i'm going to go into that
some of these could apply i think as
well to other
modes of intentional living or personal
development or philosophy as a way of
life so i think these would arise for
people
doing
living philosophy from an epicurean
perspective or cynic perspective or
whatever else we're going to go into
because you know they're they're um a
widespread
issue that are rooted in
our human nature and our damaged human
nature our screwed up human nature that
we're trying to
disentangle and straighten out using
stoicism
but then there's some that i think are
specific to stoicism because of the way
we've uh
understood things
so
we could talk about a lot of other ones
and i think maybe in the q and a and
discussion we we might and so this is
not a comprehensive list that i'm i'm uh
providing you with and i think we can
also draw a lot from our own experiences
and those of others we're doing that
when we read seneca or read epictetus
and we see them
writing to somebody or in epictetus's
case
criticizing and haranguing them and
sometimes poking fun at them when we
read marcus aurelius we're reading him
saying to himself hey you schmuck why
don't you get your act together uh over
and over again and and you know then
there's also treaty seas like you know
heracles uh fragments of ethics and
we've got a lot of material to work with
so we know that these were issues back
in the day although maybe not identified
quite so much as such and they're issues
for us
so when i was thinking about this uh and
just brainstorming i came up with a list
of ten this is not the definitive or
comprehensive list of stumbling blocks
for people interested in practicing and
understanding stoicism
um but i think
you'll see that these are
pretty
widespread and common
problems
and they broke down for me into four
categories
those that have to do primarily with
people
those that have to do in particular with
things
those that have to do with stoicism
itself understood as a philosophy of
life an intentional way of living and
then those that have to do with measure
or perspective how we
how we assess ourselves how we assess
whether we're making progress or not
and so i i'm going to start with the
ones with people but i'm just going to
read these off to you at the start so we
like in a bullet point form so with
people expectations that we have of
non-stoic others
then disappointment with those that are
identified as stoics
and
a temptation to evangelize in the wrong
way those are the three that i'm going
to talk about here
with things
we have almost two opposed examples
[Music]
being too indifferent to indifference is
one of them
and then bringing externals into one's
own stoicism is a second one
with stoicism itself understood as a
philosophy of life we have practices
that aren't working for somebody
we have expecting too much out of maxims
and then
demanding too much out of a mere part of
a larger system and then finally when it
comes to measure and perspective
working on everything at once is a big
problem that a lot of people fall into
and measuring our failures or plateaus
in the wrong ways is is another
similar problem as well so let's let's
talk about expectations of non-stoic
others
um
when we tell people that we have found
this great thing called stoicism and
it's changing our life for the better
and we embrace it there is often a
tendency to tell other people about it
and uh expect them
to respect what we're getting into and
that's crazy because
they're not stoics so
they're more likely as epictetus says he
doesn't say a stoic he says if you're
going to tell people that you're a
philosopher expect them to test you
expect them to try to provoke you
and if you do this in terms of stoicism
in part because of the
you know lower case s use of the word
where the stoic is supposed to be this
stiff upper lip and never getting you
know perturbed by anything if you tell
people that you're you're doing that
they are going to mess with you so
that's probably
not a good idea
on the other side we often expect people
once we've seen the you know great
wisdom and transformative powers of
stoicism
to embrace it themselves even though
they don't have any stake in it
and sometimes this can be quite
unfair or oppressive to other people
and it's it's as you're going to see
that one of the common themes throughout
all of these stumbling blocks is um
it's not prudent it's not a good
exercise of wisdom
to adopt that kind of perspective why
because
stoicism was developed by philosophers
philosophers who were living a life
for a world of other human beings who
are not themselves stoics and
that's the origin that's the context
that will always most likely be
the way things are so it's kind of
imprudent to expect
reality to change itself because we've
adopted some perspective on unreality
it's also very unfair to expect of other
human beings what they can't at this
point in time deliver
so i'll give you a prime example
one of my
students in a medical ethics class who
uh was going through a lot of family
difficulties she's also she's actually a
business major at one of the places i
teach she was having a lot of issues
coming up and she tried to use the
counseling services on campus found out
that they really are just for show
and they would give her two sessions and
that's it
um which seems to me you know pretty
pretty uh unfortunate and inhumane and
one of her business professors
said this to her
you know there's this thing called
stoicism you should look into it
and
didn't say anything more is is that a
kind beneficence just way to treat
another person no that's that's the
opposite of it so like throwing them out
there and saying go read some books and
and it'll sort you out when somebody is
in genuine anguish now you know if she
did study stoicism it would help her
with a lot of the things that she's
facing but to demand that at the start
of somebody
is
very you know it's it's quite imprudent
it's actually foolish
it also doing this focusing on others um
rather than oneself that's that's kind
of problematic right
uh especially if we're beginners we're
supposed to try to learn how not to pay
attention everybody else's business the
things that are in their control
and to start paying attention to what's
in our control so i think that this is
one main source of stumbling blocks
people get much more obsessed with
telling everybody else about stoicism
and how they should be stoics and
how great it is and they focus less on
what they ought to be doing as stoics
now what about people who are stoics we
sometimes get disappointed with them
and we feel as if these great
and i'm going to use the word
deliberately idols that we've set on
high
have
fallen down and broken and how how could
the philosophy be any good if you know
here i'll just take a prime example on
twitter massimo pigliucci uh sometimes
gets uh you know a hard time from people
who are like that's not very stoic of
you to criticize another person you know
or to call somebody an a-hole you know i
i think you know sometimes it's
perfectly compatible if a person
objectively is an a-hole a jerk of a
certain sort um there's there's actually
i mean if you
spent all day long tweeting about that
that's a problem but you know calling
out a person for their behavior
strikes me as a matter of justice you
know it might even involve courage if
you're punching up and
and uh you know saying something to
somebody who could actually
hurt you i mean not that you can
actually be hurt on twitter right
in any important way but
we often see people
who are
held up as as prime examples
being told that they're letting other
stoics down now we should think about
this
there aren't any saviors in stoicism
this is not epicureanism where epicurus
is called sotor right the cynics had
hercules sotor as well
and of course you know they're for for
christians there's there's a savior
figure
stoicism doesn't work that way the sage
is not a savior
and
when does it when do we actually run
into sages i mean according to the old
stuff every once every 500 years we
might not see a sage in our lifetime
um so
who are we actually concerned with the
people that the stoics identified as in
greek procultoi or in latin proficientes
the
people who are on the way they're making
progress hopefully although progress
very often looks like a
you know step forward step back step
forward step back less less of a steady
thing
all the time
and so
we probably want to keep that in mind um
and then somebody could [ __ ] yes but
they're the representatives of stoicism
what about these people who are writing
books or you know doing podcasts or
they're putting themselves forward as an
ideal well they're not
actually as far as i know putting
themselves forth as an ideal that's if i
take
somebody else out there i will pick one
of my colleagues i'll pick somebody who
if any of you have had the privilege of
knowing and interacting with you would
say well he's he's a good ways closer to
sagehood than i'll ever be and he's a
really great guy and that's christopher
gill
but christopher gill might have a bad
day and you know
curse out some cab driver while i'm
watching him and then you know when i
when i say that's not very stoic if you
turn on me with an angry face and you
know shout me off the curb or something
like that i mean i have a hard time
imagining chris doing that but
anything could happen right
if i myself expect some sort of
perfection
out of chris gill i'm the foolish one
and i'm the one who's allowing myself to
be scandalized by doing that
um epictetus in in his discourses brings
up how different people who he thinks
are
not quite sages but but at least on the
way
socrates xeno diogenes each one of them
had a very different approach he tells
us that you know zeno stuck to teaching
socrates went around questioning people
diogenes basically got in people's faces
in a very aggressive way and each one of
these was a legitimate way
of doing the sort of thing that that
epictetus thought mattered for stoicism
so that that's a second uh potential
stumbling block that we want to avoid
a third is evangelizing
or advocating stoicism in the wrong way
i i'm not against
trying to spread good words about things
which is what event you know
evangelizing is at its core
but i think a lot of times people go
about that the wrong way and it's
understandable that if you found
something that's helpful for you in your
life you would want to share it with
others that is indeed part of
beneficence which is a part of justice
right
but there is a tendency i think among
many people
not just in stoicism but any sort of
thing that improves your life and it
could be a philosophy it could even be a
diet or exercise to say this works for
me
so therefore it must work for you and
you should be doing this
think about the advice that we get as
soon as we tell somebody that we're
doing a new kind of exercise oh you
should be lifting a different way the
way that i do it the way that i think
you should do it
and so i think a lot of evangelizing
works like that you know taking cold
showers is is changing my life you
should all take cold showers too you
know
um
what we need to do
instead it's not that we can't say hey
this is helpful you should try this
but we always have to exercise the
reserve clause we always have to say
how invested am i getting in that person
changing their mind and their behavior
i can communicate information to them i
don't have to expect them to
change to to suit me we also might want
to keep in mind something else that epic
details brought up with respect to
socrates
how often did socrates succeed epictetus
tells it one in a thousand
right
that's you know imagine if you were a
doctor and you saved one out of a
thousand of your patients you probably
wouldn't stay a doctor very long
fortunately the stakes are lower when
you're just talking to people but you
know socrates didn't allow that to
discourage him
uh from from doing that and we probably
should expect about that sort of rate of
rate of return as well
we want to think if we if we're going to
communicate with people about stoicism
we want to practice the virtues so it's
not just about courage being bold enough
to tell the story
it's also about prudence
how do we talk to people
um do we do it in the right way at the
right time
presenting things
in the amount that people can take in
sometimes waiting and not saying
anything is the most pro most prudent
thing to do
justice this is also where once again
the expectations of non-stoic others if
somebody is really struggling somebody
is really suffering somebody is dealing
with difficult stuff
merely telling them they should practice
stoicism does not strike me as a a just
way to behave it's actually quite cruel
instead
what we can do is create opportunities
for people to learn about stoicism but
then like i said before we have to
exercise that reserve clause we have to
realize that
they have to see the point to it
we can't force that on them
when we turn to thinking about things
the whole world of things that we're
involved in a big stumbling block for
stoics is this notion of indifference
with a ts
rather than indifference as an attitude
they both come from the same
greek diaphora
the things that literally don't make a
difference right
a prime example of this is the amount of
hairs on your head whether it's even or
odd that's one of the examples that
diogenes layer tastes and
uh ariastitimus both give another very
interesting example the color of one's
skin
the stoics in ancient times thought that
that doesn't really matter at all that's
that's a total indifferent it's neither
good nor bad
because they had very different
understandings of ethnicity race um
markers for that then we unfortunately
do it in our world right so that that
might be something to follow up on down
the line
indifference do in fact matter from a
stoic perspective there was a stoic who
is a a renegade um who uh gets talked
about by cicero and and by diogenes
zlaertes who said that the indifference
we just don't care about them at all
right that's not the position of zeno or
the later stoics who we study
indifference do matter
they just don't matter as much as virtue
and vice or happiness and misery so
wealth does matter poverty does matter
it just doesn't matter enough to make
you happy or miserable or a good person
or a bad person
and i think a lot of people when they
learn about stoicism they wind up taking
an all-or-nothing approach where they
they express themselves saying things
like
you know
it's it's stoic uh there was a thing on
twitter about this a while back it's
really stoic to not give a an f about
anything well that's completely wrong
you know that would be imprudent that
would be unjust
that's not even courageous because
courage in the real sense
means you know resisting things and
standing up for things and combating the
things that that really do in fact uh
matter and some of those might be
indifference because as epictetus points
out to us things that are indifferent or
external to us things that are outside
our control
how we deal with them
how we make use of them the crisis in
greek
really does matter and is up to us and
is a matter for pro-racist for our our
choice about things
um so
we really we do want to think about how
we maintain this kind of tension right
clearly the indifference do matter to
some degree
how do we determine
when they matter why they matter well
that's where the things that that are
more valuable have to come into play
like the virtues
which include prudence
there's a there's a
opposite sort of scandal i think that
people do which
trips themselves up and they don't
realize it as a way in which they're
deviating themselves from from where
they want to go
and that's bringing externals into their
stoicism itself
getting too concerned about things that
don't really matter as if they're part
of
their stoic practice and some of that
we're going to get to a little bit later
when we talk about proper measure
i think a great example of this is stoic
merch and tattoos
people think that if they buy themselves
a challenge coin
which is a weird practice anyway there's
a whole other conversation i have about
how challenge coins which were a rarity
when i was in the the us military have
become you know
this inflated sign that almost anybody
can you know get them to get their hands
on there's a whole story to be told
there about it
um
having a coin of any sort doesn't make
you any more stoic
it might be a useful aid to memory but
you know would be an even more useful
aid to memory
remembering stuff in your head
developing a practice where you don't
actually need to have
something in your pocket
to whip out
and
you know display your connection with
the stoic community a lot of people get
get tattoos and i see a lot of posts
about this and i'm not you know i'm not
saying that this is a terrible thing or
anything but it really does lose
perspective
there's nothing about putting ink on an
indifferent which is your body according
to stoicism traditionally understood
that is going to make you more stoic
right and it doesn't matter whether you
write it in greek or
latin or english or norwegian or pick
whatever you want i mean do pick a
language that you you know because
otherwise you'll be like those people
who get you know
characters like chinese characters and
it spells like a menu item or something
and then you look kind of silly
but
merch tattoos
those are things that apply to the
indifference
i think there's a lot of people as well
who do focus on more on belonging and
signaling and social status within the
stoic community
and less about
their own practice
you know this is this is a way of
shifting concern
outward into the world where you're
likely to be disappointed this this lays
you up for some of those other things
like thinking that stoic figures are
somehow saintly uh types i mean
even saints understood in christian
context a lot of them were kind of kind
of uh you know flawed characters too
right so um stoic procoptoir are going
to be as well
the last thing that i think falls under
there
and some people might not be happy to
hear this buying books um
you can have too many books seneca says
this explicitly
you
unless you're actually reading the books
and they're the right books because
there's a lot of you know good books and
a lot of bad books out there on on
stoicism
you're not actually improving yourself
you're not helping your stoic practice
and internalized philosophy
by putting books on a shelf lucian who
who is not a stoic lucian of samosota
has a very funny piece called the
ignorant book buyer and it's about a guy
who lines his uh
study
with all these books that he's buying
and thinks that simply acquiring them by
you know force of osmosis or ownership
is going to make him a smarter guy and
he's he's as ignorant as you could
possibly be
i think some people do that at times
with with stoicism and like i said this
is this is a stumbling block where
people trip themselves up while they're
actually thinking they're doing a good
thing for themselves
what about um
stoicism itself so stoicism is a
practical philosophy there are
what hadeau calls spiritual exercises
most people just call them philosophical
practices that you engage in ranging
from identifying what's in your control
what's not in your control to negative
visualization to you know voluntary
discomfort
you guys all know the whole gamut of
these sorts of things
um
practices don't always work for
everybody
i i take cold showers
but i don't do it as a matter of course
to like toughen myself up because you
know i usually take a cold shower when i
get out of the sauna at the gym because
it's nice to cool down you know the same
practice can do very different things
there's a dialectic between practice and
study and reflection the more practice
you do
it helps you understand stoic philosophy
and then the stoic philosophy should be
informing the practice and they should
be building off of each other
doing practices just by themselves just
for the sake of doing practices
is not really stoicism john sellers
points this out in an interview that we
did with him on a radio show a while
back and it was really great to hear him
say that that just doing practices is
not
not enough
there's also kind of a relativity to
practices
not every practice is for every person
and
if you try a practice and it doesn't
work out for you that doesn't mean that
stoicism has failed and it doesn't even
mean necessarily that you have failed or
that you're doing it wrong right
it could mean that that practice is just
not going to ever pay off for you or
it's not going to pay off at this point
in time
you know or you're not in the right kind
of situation for it some people
shouldn't do negative visualization
donald robertson has pointed this out
when it comes to people who have been
you know terribly traumatized
if you are dealing with some really deep
rooted trauma from abuse then trying to
think about the thing that's a trigger
for you might not be the best idea to do
at this point in time right so even
negative visualization which gets gets
recommended as a universal
panacea
it's it's not that you have to be again
prudent in in which practices you take
on
another important aspect that we're
going to talk a little bit more about
later
routines
stoic routines practice routines can in
fact become routine they can become
mindless and stale
and
then they're probably not going to be
helping you out and you have to reassess
over and over again so i think that
putting practices in a proper
perspective
is very important for avoiding this this
particular stumbling block
on the other side so we have practices
things that you do
we have things that you say or things
that you read or things that you think
maxims right what we nowadays call
quotes
passages that are taken out of text some
of them are recommended by people like
epictetus when he says have ready at
hand when you get into this sort of
situation to say to yourself xyz marcus
is in fact saying those things to
himself in the meditations seneca has a
whole letter about these which i highly
recommend to all of you
where somebody is asking him for quotes
and he says
i'm not gonna give you any for for these
reasons here uh and then he relents and
says ah why not i'll give you a few and
he gives gives them some um
maxims just like practices are
contextual they are not helpful for
every single situation
you have to understand the maxim in
order for it to be of any use to you
they require unpacking there's a lot of
quotes out there that people like to
post
and write down for themselves and repeat
to themselves
seneca is super clear about this without
some sort of connection to the larger
stoic system they're losing most of
their efficacy and some of them can
actually be um dangerous or damaging to
you
if you're misusing them you know telling
yourself for example as you go through a
bad breakup that you know
this this appearance is nothing to me
that's probably not going to be good for
you right so you want to be prudent in
in how you uh use your maxims um
some of them you know are actually
uh they need a lot of unpacking a great
example is the obstacle is the way
is the obstacle really the way in every
single case sometimes the obstacle is
just the obstacle you know and sometimes
you would be foolish to keep on butting
your head against that particular
obstacle
sometimes you want to go around the
obstacle that might be the way but the
obstacle itself isn't the way so we can
do this with all sorts of other
stoic passages quotes maxims whatever
you want to call them
we need to be
rational as we're
thinking them through and applying them
rather than just parroting them as if
they're going to magically help us
and this leads to another sort of
source of stumbling blocks
people will seize upon
parts of stoicism as if it's the
totality of stoicism the best example of
this is the dichotomy of control i've
seen people saying stoicism you know the
foundation of it or the essence of
stoicism is the dichotomy of control
that shows up very very late in stoic
philosophy the first person to
explicitly formulate it epictetus right
we don't know if it was in some of the
classic stoics like
xeno
and chrysippus it might have been
we see things sort of like it in cicero
describing stoicism we see some things
like it in seneca
um
we also in the epitome of stoic you know
uh ethics and in diogenesis we don't see
an emphasis on the dichotomy of control
so we should be really wary in that case
and in other cases of saying this is the
only thing that counts this is the
the cornerstone
as seneca tells us stoicism is a complex
system it's better to think of it less
as
a single star and more like an entire
constellation and not a not a simple one
like the big dipper you know but a
really complicated one or you might
think of it like a mosaic where you need
all these different pieces in the
composition
now that might lead to some dismay you
say well i haven't read all the stoic
texts or you know how am i going to
learn all of this stuff and you know
it's something that we grow into it's
something that we build within ourselves
you can have a more and a less
but you don't want to hold yourself back
by saying i've got it figured out
i've got everything that i need
now we come to the last two and here
we're dealing with
things that have to do with how we
measure our success and how we how we
plan things out
it's a big mistake
recognized not just by stoics but also
by other authors a prime example of this
is john cassian the uh one of the great
monastic writers uh in in the west
working on everything at once thinking
that you're gonna change every single
part of yourself is setting yourself up
for failure
you can generally only work on a bit of
yourself at a time and this is in part
because as epictetus teaches us we are
pro-racist we are our faculty of choice
and pro-racist compels pro-races you are
using a higher part of yourself to
look at to unscrew up
that very part of yourself
so you can't change it all at once
you know you have to be selective on
what you're going to work on and
forgiving with yourself for all of your
screw-ups when it comes to other things
so if like your big thing is anger
management but you also ought to you
know exercise some temperance and eating
and drinking
maybe work on the anger management first
and after you've actually got that
halfway down now you can start worrying
about dieting and exercise and you know
not having
fifth helpings at the buffet or whatever
it's going to be right and we could we
could do it vice versa with that as well
but you you really can't
do everything at once and if you try to
you're going to fail and you're going to
feel really bad about it and it will
probably lead you away from yet one more
failed system that you've invested in
for a while
the last thing is measuring failure or
plateaus
we're all going to screw up
and you know again the classic stoics
they talk about this they all say that
they've screwed up
marcus is actually haranguing himself
sometimes
and we want to keep this in proper
perspective we don't want to hide things
from ourselves oh i didn't really screw
up or the great thing that i'm going to
do tomorrow will totally make up for
this
i think many of many of us have fallen
into that trap i know i certainly have
but we're not just simply going back to
square one
you know we build up practice over a
while and we change ourselves gradually
so
reminding ourselves that
when we fail we have the opportunity to
not fail the next time and to make
something of it can help take some
stress off of ourselves um sometimes
when we've been practicing for a while
we feel like we hit a plateau and we're
just
idling along
travis hume uh the applying stoicism
organizer he and i have been talking
about this for a while and i told him
about you know the concept of the dark
knight of the soul and you know
spiritual progress this is something
that the stoics didn't themselves
thematize that much but i think is is
really quite common you've actually made
some progress and now you're just kind
of idling along
well you're not just idling along if
you're if you're still reading you're
still thinking you're still behaving
you're still
choosing you are slowly growing
something within yourself and you can
remind yourself of that if you don't
there's a tendency to say
ah this is just boring routine why
should i keep doing this and that's
allowing yourself to be
scandalized allowing yourself to have
impediments thrown in your way
so those are the
ten that i thought were you know worth
talking about there's lots of other ways
there's like an infinite amount of ways
if aristotle is right that we can go
wrong
but i thought those those might be um
common helpful ones that i saw a lot of
nodding heads a lot of us can relate to
i've done probably all of them at one
point in time not necessarily with
stoicism but at least with something
i'm willing to bet that quite a few of
you have as well
and so i look forward to
you know digging into this a bit deeper
as we we continue our conversation
i've talked at you enough and thanks for
uh
coming along for the ride on this and
hopefully it's been helpful
you